in the last few years Kevin Costner has
transformed himself from a big-screen
legend into the small screen star of one
of the most watched shows on television
paramount network's modern-day Western
melodrama Yellowstone Costner plays John
Dutton the head of a Montana ranching
dynasty who's lusted after land borders
the titular National Park and a
reservation occupied by indigenous
peoples what's he saying says that it's
wrong for one man to own all this while
Costner has always brought a certain
movie star swagger to Yellowstone the
series has set itself apart from its
competition by taking advantage of its
setting to infuse a big-screen Verve
into its narrative as it happens the
show's Montana setting was one of the
biggest deciding factors for Costner to
make his first TV appearance on a
serialized TV series speaking at
deadlines the contenders Emmys
presentation in April 2019 Costner
revealed that the reason he agreed to
star on Yellowstone had everything to do
with its location which he felt would
remind audiences of the beauty of the
real world he said the idea of seeing
wide-open spaces when the land was
almost like the Garden of Eden to know
that places like this still exist in our
country adding drama against its
backdrop and actually understand in the
realest terms that the meat that arrives
on our table is still coming from
somewhere we don't see that enough I
don't think we get outside enough if you
will
Yellowstone is hardly Costner's first
brush with the wide-open spaces of the
American West or even the western genre
for that matter the actor has frequently
saddled up and hit the dusty trails over
the course of his career breaking
through in the 1985 action era Silverado
before appearing in 1994's Wyatt Earp
and later producing directing and
starring in 2003's
open range a cinematic trifecta the
Costner had previously tackled to the
tune of two Academy Awards when his
wispy anti-western drama Dances with
Wolves gray screens back in 1990
I've always wanted to see the frontier
do you want to see the frontier yes sir
before it's gone in 2017 Costner
revealed that he had co-written a 10
hour long Western project that he'd
loved to direct for the big or small
screen speaking with vulture he's shared
I have another Western I have co-written
with some people and I would like to
play out the second half of my career
directing more I've constantly given the
movies I found to directors who I
thought could do it better but there are
a lot of voices in my ear from my family
saying you need to direct the movies you
fall in love with so I think I will
as for Yellowstone the show continues to
make stark use of its stunning vistas
which serve as a fascinating backdrop
and counterpoint to its modern-day
setting though Costner hasn't yet helmed
an episode of the series you can go
ahead and add it to the list of his
memorable Western ventures with the
actor bringing as much drama presence
and majesty to the show as the Montana
sky itself you can also rest assured
that paramount Network brass and series
creator Taylor Sheridan will be making
full use of both on Yellowstone's
already greenlit 3rd season
Yellowstone's second season took a swing
for the fences mentality in terms of its
many narrative arcs and its finale
delivered a definitive ends to a couple
of the series more compelling storylines
with a mix of shootouts kidnappings
plenty of mano-a-mano type fisticuffs
though producers have already gone on
record that season 3 of Yellowstone will
likely level off a bit in terms of sub
manic melodrama and unabashed
bloodletting it's a safe bet that the
show will still be steeped in searing
political and personal dramas for season
3 what won't change on Yellowstone
season 3 is its stunning sprawling
Montana landscape that Costner and
series fans love so much after all the
Dutton's are far from done defending
their land from outsiders and
competitors and a handful of new faces
are coming to Big Sky Country for the
new season
these include Lost alum Josh Holloway
and new world star Corey Anka kilcher
season 3 of Yellowstone is currently in
production and is set to premiere on
June 17th 2020 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]